яка ситуація із приватними дидсадками в
Україні чи є потреба у таких дошкільних
закладах і хто регулює їхню діяльність
про це розпитаємо заступницю міністра
освіти і науки України із питань
дошкілля Євгенію смірнову Я вітаю вас
пані Євгенію Вітаю вас Будь ласка
розкажіть яка нині ситуація із
приватними дисатками в Україні дивіться
за даними держстату на 22-й рік в нас
499 закладів а якщо наприклад ми
порівняємо з 21-м То це в 21-му
497 приватних закладів якраз за 23й рік
подаються дані і у кінці квітня ми вже з
вами будемо бачити
ситуацію більш свіжищих і оновлених
даних а також хочеться знаєте не
виокремлювати тільки приватні заклади А
ще пару слів сказати про комунальні
заклади що наразі В 24му році в нас
існує
12603 дошкільних дитячих заклади частина
із них На жаль Вони працюють дистанційно
в зв'язку з війною це
2290 закладів Це залежить від безпекової
ситуації від рішення котре приймає
військова адміністрація а також
наявності
укриття в нас в дистанційній формі
освіти зараз працює Запорізька Донецька
Луганська Харківська і Херсонська
область Скажіть що потребує дошкільна
система освіти України нових дитячих
садочків зокрема приватного типу саме
головне взагалі
в будь-якій освіті особливо в дошкільній
це потреби дитини і дитина наразі в нас
покриття дошкільною освітою
72%. Ну якщо бути більш точнішим там 70
2,9% тобто в нас не всіх дітей є доступ
до дошкільної освіти хоча це
така базова норма котра Ну наприклад
введена нобелівським лауреатом що early
childhood
це 13% прибутку в країні потім ці
дослідження вони були проведені на
протязі 30 років і на них можна прям
рунтовно
спиратися тому що можна СКА сзати
звичайно ми маємо забезпечити дошкільною
освітою кожну дитину і жоден не має
права бути виключеним А ми маємо ще
говорити про різні форми здобуття
дошкільної освіти це можуть бути знаєте
як в нашому класичному розумінні
приватні дошкільні заклади Ми також
починаємо зараз пілотування
альтернативних форм здобуття дошкільної
освіти наприклад сімейний дитячий садок
Він Він дуже популярний в Німеччині коли
адаптується
простір або приватного будинку або це
може бути квартира ну тобто доволі
по-різному
а головний компонент котрий має бути
збережений - це безпека наших карапузів
а тому мені здається що нам 100%
потрібний ріст мережі А щоб кожна дитина
була включена в освіту і це можливо
завдяки абсолютно різним формам І тут
також хочеться додати про форму окрім
сімейного це може бути корпоративний
дитячий садок котрий можна відкривати
біля підприємства щоби особливо під час
повітряних
тривог військового стану що зараз
відбувається дуже хочеться щоби Малюки
були поруч і ми хочемо
запровадити щоб підприємства на своїй
території могли відкривати дошкільні
осередки корпоративні садоки
скажіть покроково як нині в Україні
відкрити дитячий садок сімейного типу
або ж корпоративного типу Та ми зараз
розробляємо цей процес і дуже я
сподіваюся найближчим часом вийдемо вже
в таку повноцінну комунікацію Ми хочемо
щоб були знаєте і покрокова інструкція і
можливість а від нас це потребує
багатьох змін в нормативно-правові акти
щоб ця можливість вона розросталася і
стала знаєте більш
впровадженою назад які основні вимоги до
таких садочків Я перепрошую хто буде
перевіряти середовище освіту вихователів
стан здоров'я вихователів і все інше Хто
ліцензує Розкажіть будь ласка про це
детальніше так Да да я розумію що це
найважливіше питання Дивіться це питання
комплексне і воно потребує якраз
комплексного опрацювання це тіла робочх
груп
тому що для України це таке доволі
доволі
нове нова форма дошкільної освіти але
насправді в усьому світі вона існує тому
зараз на всі ці питання котрі
якраз ліцензування які нам потрібні
внести зміни в санітарну в санітарні
вимоги вони якраз опрацьовуються робочою
групою щоби ця практика тому що
насправді навіть в минулому законі
котрий про дошкільну освіту там була
така форма як сімейні дитячі садочки але
вона не впроваджувалася так широко а і
зараз ми бачимо проблему що в
нас 72% охопленя дітей дошкільною
освітою ми маємо змінювати цю ситуацію а
ми маємо дивитися не тільки на великі
міста а і на
невеликі селища де діти потребують
дошкільної освіти на вашу думку чому
така ситуація мало дітей можуть
дістатися до навчального закладу
дошкільного чи немає таких фахівців чи
немає приміщень чому не всі охочі можуть
потрапити до садочка дивіться насправді
тут я би сказала проблема насправді
комплексна і нам її потрібно розглядати
абсолютно з різних боків і тут варто
бути відвертими тому що на зараз в
Україні середня заробітна плата
вихователя - це
грн в нас є потужний брак кадрів котре
котрим котри потребує саме дошкільна
ланка
АА в нас на жаль є 83 громади на зараз
де взагалі відсутня дошкільна освіта
але на жаль це дуже негативна тенденція
тому що про що це каже що якщо немає
дошкільної освіти це немає дітей
виходить і це невірно І тому ми якраз і
почали впровадження пілоту по
альтернативним формам тому що форма
дошкільної освіти Вона має і може бути
різною але тут питання дуже комплексне і
Ми якраз займаємося опрацюванням від
моделювання по заробітним платам ми
залучили також партнерів таких як
Світовий банк до якраз моделювання
заробітних плат
вихователів і зміни також зараз в
комітеті прохо проходить до кінця
обговорення закон України 8030 по
дошкільній освіті і ми як Міністерство
освіти і науки сподіваємося що Знаєте
він буде такий інноваційний він дасть
потужну можливість нашим дошкільним
закладам розвиватися що вони самостійно
зможуть формувати за необхідни собі
штатний розпис А ми не будемо його
керувати зверху тому що я багато
подорожую спілкуюся з вихователями
взагалі з працівниками дошкілля це
неймовірні люди котрі
а роблять Ну я не знаю від лількових
театрів театрів шкарпеток з дітьми в
деяких містах при дошкільних дитячих
закладах в нас є
басейни які відвідують дошкільнят та і
хочеться щоб цей закон якби дав
можливість усій Ланці дуже потужно
розвиватися а
приніс ті інновації котрі потребують
сучасні дошкільнята і вихователі А ми зі
свого боку будемо всіляко підтримувати
змінювати наші політики і тут мені
хочеться підкреслити знаєте зону
відповідальності мон Що Ми формуємо та
реалізуємо державну політику тобто коли
закон буде прийнятий і Ми якраз вже
візьмемося побачимо його фінальни після
другого читання і візьмемося за
розробку всіх нормативно-правових актів
котрі буде потребувати сфера і ще будь
ласка пані Євгенія поточніть якщо ми
говоримо про ранній розвиток дитини от
ви наводили приклад на дитячих садочках
Німеччини якщо беремо вік від нуля до
трьох років чи можливо відкриття таких
садочків сімейного типу в Україні і в
такому випадку хто регулюватиме їхню
діяльність зокрема в Ланці забезпечення
харчуванням вихователями і так далі а це
якраз іде на обговоренні закону про
дошкільну освіту і Я дуже сподіваюся що
скоро ми з вами побачимо фінальну
редакцію Скажіть будь ласка закон Про
який ми говоримо що нині розглядається в
робочій групі коли планується його
прийняття коли вже зможемо бачити
останню редакцію наскільки мені відомо
що зараз
проходять фіналізацію обговорення в
комітеті і комітетом він буде винесений
в зал Я дуже сподіваюся що навесні ми з
вами побачимо новий закон будемо
очікувати поки Дякую вам за інформацію
що знайшли час для нашого ефіру Нагадую
що говорили із заступницею міністра
освіти і науки України з питань дошкілля
Євгенією
смірновою